Speaker 1: There are still endless gobs of
Republican elected officials who defend Trump.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
You know the folks.
But there are more and more Republican elected
officials who are saying this is too much.
Now, I don't say that these people are brave.
Listen, the guy's been impeached twice.
Humiliated.
The country has been indicted twice, is admitting
to crimes in speeches made in front of his
supporters.
These aren't brave people for doing this now.
But I care about the political ramifications.
Here is Ken Buck.
Starting to go in the direction of this may
have been too much.
Speaker 2: How would you have done it if you
were the prosecutor then after 14 months of
asking and then, of course, seeing the surveillance
tapes that showed even after a subpoena, they
didn't get that the former president defied
a subpoena, according to this man.
Speaker 5: And it goes beyond that.
He hid documents, you know, purposely putting
him in a shower, purposely putting him on
a stage.
So there clearly is an intent to hide or was
intent that he knew what he talked to.
His attorneys so brief these documents that
no doubt that that it was a difficult situation.
It's just the precedent from my position,
my my view of searching a former president's
home, that that is just unseemly in this country.
I don't know what the answer is, whether there
were alternatives or not.
Speaker 2: I want to ask about the notion
of the former president being a candidate
for president.
Again, as you said, he is innocent until proven
guilty.
That is the way the system works and should
work.
But given the allegations you just discussed,
some of them, the specifics of the way he
allegedly mishandled classified information,
would you feel comfortable with Donald Trump
as president again?
Speaker 5: Well, I would not feel comfortable
with a convicted felon in the White House.
So what a big boy.
Speaker 1: How brave.
Now, understand, even for Ken Buck, like he's
still saying, a convicted felon, certainly
the allegations against Trump wouldn't influence
his vote, but he's at least drawing some line
in the sand as pathetic and weak.
I mean, it it is a cop out, but it's also
pathetic that this is what it takes to get
them to even revise their thoughts.
Then Mike Pompeo went on Fox News yesterday,
and he also is saying this is extraordinarily
serious.
Speaker 5: With Donald Trump is facing and
is it right to charge him?
Brian, good morning.
Great to be with you.
Two things i think are both true at this point.
First, if the allegations are true and there's
lots of indications that they are.
President trump had classified documents where
he shouldn't have had them and then when given
the opportunity, return them.
Me, he chose not to do that for whatever reason.
That's just.
Brian, you talked about me having classified
documents.
I handle thousands and thousands of them over
my time in Congress and then as a CIA director
and secretary of state.
I suppose we can all make mistakes and get
into the wrong place.
But when somebody identifies that, you've
got to turn them in.
So that's just that's inconsistent with protecting
America's soldiers, sailors, airmen and Marines.
And if the allegations are true, some of these
were pretty serious, important documents.
Speaker 1: Now, the question for Mike Pompeo,
even though he's being big and tough now,
is you were secretary of state.
Are you saying Trump never did anything wrong
until he left the Oval Office?
Because that's becoming increasingly difficult
to believe from all of these folks who say,
listen, everything he did as president was
fine, but this one thing he did since leaving
that I'm not okay with, very difficult to
believe that former Speaker of the House Paul
Ryan was on with CBS.
Now, he is not a Trump guy.
We already know that.
But he is also hammering Trump very hard from
another wing of Republicans that seem to be
turning on him.
Speaker 5: And this one's national security.
This one is different.
I used to have these same documents myself
as speaker of the House.
So I think this goes beyond just some petty
thing.
Now, my guess is Trump will play this politically
pretty well and make this weaponization argument
and make this about Joe Biden's Justice Department.
And that's going to have some political saliency.
So I don't think Mark was wrong in saying
that there's some political sting here, But
I can't help but think the weight in the baggage
of all of this and this one's national security,
this one, I think we want a nominee who's
not weighed down with so much baggage in order
to win this election.
Speaker 1: All right.
So Paul Ryan saying Trump is not the right
guy.
Paul Ryan was saying that before this second
indictment.
Anyway, Fox News senior political.
Analyst Brit HUME actually explains the entire
thing here on this second indictment.
This is not an elected official, but Brit
HUME is sort of the epitome of just put your
finger to the wind and go wherever the Republicans
want you to go.
He's making it clear that this could indeed
be a moment for many Republicans to back away
from Trump.
Speaker 2: What are your thoughts this morning?
Speaker 5: Well, I think that there are two
things can be true at the same time.
One of them being that there is indeed a two
tier system of justice in which people like
Hillary Clinton skate while Donald Trump is
indicted for wrong.
Speaker 1: And no evidence of that at this
time.
But okay, can you please continue?
Speaker 5: Or similar or similar events?
That does not mean, however, that the indictment
is not valid and serious and it's details
are pretty damning.
And I think that some of these politicians
who are quickly in standing with Trump and
and seem not to have thoroughly read or understood
the indictment, may want to may want to back
away a little bit and and and let this that
the details of this indictment sink in.
And when they sink in with the public, there
may be a shift in sentiment on this.
Speaker 1: That is for sure.
That is for sure.
And we are seeing that.
A couple more of these.
CNN reporter Manu Raju spoke to Republican
Congressman Steve Womack and Republican Congressman
Tim Burchett and some others.
And many of these are already backing away.
Speaker 5: They have serious concerns about
anybody that has a reckless disregard for
the handling of classified documents.
A military guy, he.
Speaker 2: Allegedly had national security
information.
Speaker 5: Very problematic is the reason
I'm not not defending it.
Would you be okay with that of a convicted
felon as your nominee?
And I just have to read the conviction.
But no.
Honestly, on the surface, I wouldn't.
That doesn't look good.
Speaker 1: There you go.
So a number of these Republicans now, I want
to be crystal clear with you guys.
I am not presenting these to you as examples
of bravery or, you know, moral clarity or
any of it.
It is simply a sign that this may be what
allows and I think allows really is the right
word, allows inside a Republican support for
Trump to publicly collapse.
We're going to continue watching it.
What just one more little note on this.
Pence now also saying he can't defend the
allegations in the Trump indictment.
Pence on the New York indictment was saying
political, all that stuff.
Now, Pence, after seeing this new federal
indictment, even Pence is saying he can't
defend that.
So this may be a change.
Just imagine where we will be 7 to 10 days
from now.